dans ce petit café du quartier Rosemont
une table festive trop en à l'entrée
fruits séché au sirop et agneau en sauce
en cercle le brique un chausson salé qui
fait saliver
un festin prêt pour la tombée du jour
mais personne n'y plonge sa fourchette
en ce moment c'est le ramadan pendant 30
jours les musulmans jeunes entre le
lever du jour et la tombée de la nuit
au café on serre les clients et on
s'affaire à préparer les plats du soir
tous deux d'origine algérienne Kahina et
son mari Amir ont ouvert le café de
l'artisanat un lieu convivial qui met de
l'avant la cuisine et la culture
d'Afrique du Nord
[Musique]
le fameux brique est un incontournable
de leur menu alors la brique porte bien
son nom puisque ça aura la forme d'une
brique à la fin
difficile d'affirmer d'où vient le
nombril mais il aurait probablement des
origines turques certaines personnes
disent la brique d'autres le briquent
une chose est sûre c'est un plat salé
qu'on cuisine depuis des lunes
purée de pommes de terre olives vertes
oignons caramélisés fromage une touche
de piment et un œuf constitue la recette
de base mais on prépare souvent le brick
avec les restes de la semaine ou ses
envies du moment je suis algérien je
vais parler pour ça je vais défendre la
brique algérienne je dirais que c'est un
héritage vraiment ottoman les Ottomans
qui en colonisé l'Algérie en laissait
cette tradition dans une ville en
Algérie qui s'appelle Annaba et depuis
c'est devenu une tradition algérienne
aussi c'est toujours un régal alors la
brique est toujours posée sur notre
table durant le Ramadan sa campagne
généralement la chorba ça fait un bon
repas et on est bien calé pour pour
continuer notre journée
[Musique]
et là
ça me fascine le cru à l'intérieur
comment vous le travaillez est-ce que on
doit savoir quelque chose d'être déjà
avant de craquer la coquille non il y a
rien de particulier à savoir juste avoir
la bonne technique par contre il
faudrait essayer de le mettre au milieu
donc je vais mettre un petit peu de
pression je vais faire comme un puits
pour que l'oeuf coule à l'intérieur
et je vais commencer la conception de ma
brique la feuille est si mince donc
c'est vraiment quand on emballe quand on
lui donne la forme de brique c'est au
jour de feuilles toujours de feuilles
oui pour que ça se déchire pas à la
cuisson
ça nous permet aussi de lui donner une
plus belle forme parce que en la
maîtrise avec une deuxième feuille
c'est moins fragile
[Musique]
ça sera sur la table ce soir exactement
ça sera encore aujourd'hui et demain à
chaque fois qu'on brise le jeûne en fin
de journée
ça c'est l'indispensable et c'est la
première chose avec laquelle on commence
pour encourager
de l'essayer mais maintenant vous me
rassurez plus que ça
[Musique]
même si les feuilles de brick s'achètent
un tout petit prix dans les épiceries
orientales Kahina voulait tout de même
la préparer selon la tradition on fait
vraiment comme le grand mère dans
qu'elle prenne quatre verres identiques
et elle mesure la même chose on a un
verre de farine un verre de semoule fine
une pincée de sel on a trois cuillères à
soupe d'huile d'olive
on va finir avec deux verres d'eau
[Applaudissements]
donc il vous faut un grand pinceau comme
celui-là
[Musique]
quand c'est cuit ça commence à se
détacher tout seul
[Musique]
et voilà
à côté ça fait cuire d'un seul côté
[Musique]
merci
bon appétit merci
vous avez préparé tout ça pour nous
alors il y a petit trésor à l'intérieur
de cette brique le petit trésor qui fait
la surprise c'est vraiment le coulant
d'ailleurs il faut faire attention en ce
moment c'est mieux d'être à table pour
éviter les dégâts alors comment je vous
souhaiterais bon ramadan
merci à vous